[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
my name is captain jefferson kyle kidd
and i'm here tonight to read the news
from across this great world of ours
so they pay you to tell stories i ain't
never heard of that as a thing a man
could do
it's not a rich man's occupation as you
can see
[Music]
hi stop stop i'm not gonna hurt
you do you understand english
friend
says your name is johanna leonberger
indians took you when they attack your
family six years prior
the mother of father and sister
wolverine
well they passed
she's got family down in castroville
captain why are you doing this
she needs to laugh and dream
she needs new memories
roads closed is that the law
it is now
captain you johanna
i do not have a clue as to the care of a
child
it's a photograph
that's my wife
you can certainly handle a horse
that there's a horse
captain make no mistake
captain where it is she's that captive
out of wichita falls
what do you want how much you offer this
child is not for sale
[Music]
so she thinks she's an indian now
she's something in between ladies and
gentlemen
these are stories of men and women very
much like you
waiting for better days to come
ah you can't ever and i'm taking her
[Music]
home
[Music]
you